so hi everybody my name is Etienne
königsberg I'm a front-end Software
Architect here at the New York Times
today I'm gonna be talking about the
very real history of our web performance
efforts here at the New York Times
before I dive in I wanted to share with
you this tweet by Steve Souders himself
if you're not familiar with Steve
Souders
it's the place to start when you're
talking about web performance he tweeted
his performance of the web getting
better or worse
my past week was painfully slow marred
by top sites with bad web perf is it too
hard I don't know if the New York Times
was among these sites that Steve was
having trouble with we've known that
we've had a little bit of a performance
problem I like to think that he's
checking our site and he's actually
complaining for real that our site is
slow so that we make it fast for him but
I'm going to get back to this question
about whether it's too hard so while I
was preparing for this talk I was
thinking that this is a very real story
and it reminded me of a Geico ad from
about 2006 that I just kind of wanted to
share with you if so just give me one
sec to play Paulo Stella is a real guyco
customer not an actor so to help tell
her story we hired that announcer guy
from the movies when the storm hit both
our cars were totally underwater in a
world where both of our cars were
totally underwater we thought it would
take forever to get some help but a new
wind was about to blow well Geico we had
our check in two days pay back this time
is for real
Geico real service real savings so I
thought about doing this entire talk and
movie announcer voice I didn't think I'd
be able to keep it up all the way
through colt is actually the expert at
that so you should check out his talk on
National Talk Like a Pirate Day that was
actually really great kudos so in a
world of static pages pages on our
website are published basically like you
would a newspaper somebody hits a button
and these the content goes through
templates and is written to disk and we
mix it with proprietary language that we
compile to give a little bit of
dynamicism on the server side and it was
fast we have about 1 million of the
static pages since
2004 and republishing them is really not
an option for us if hypothetically it
took about five seconds to republish one
of these pages 5,000,000 seconds I think
comes out to about two months we can't
redo we can't be doing that every time
we make a change so what what ends up
happening is it's extremely hard for us
to change markup once it's been
published and every time we make a
change it's only present from the day we
deployed onward which means we have an
unknown number of permutations of these
markups to handle and support over time
so our front-end assets are JavaScript
and CSS have to handle all of these
permutations and in order to be able to
change these files since we can't change
the asset path because the HTML is
static we have to keep the the time to
live the cash expiration time out very
low on these files which is a
performance bad practice and we also
don't really know what pages on the site
call which assets in general so I want
to talk about our CSS history we didn't
really have a CSS framework which means
we have a lot of repetitive styles files
were imported basically as needed style
sheets approached the at the import
limits in IE 31 total and maybe up to
three nested levels deep there was
inconsistent load style we were using
link tags in one case and right after it
using a style tag with an ad import
directive and basically we also have to
deal with web producers who go through
and they're able to modify the look and
feel of our page on the fly as the news
happens so they can be dropped into our
content system and appear anywhere on
the page in the JavaScript department
Java is very ad hoc since most that a
NamUs ism was on the server side we
basically use j/s basically as needed to
fix cross browser issues to do whit's
that respond to events by the user in
the browser most of the variables and
functions are global script tags are
dropped wherever they were needed you
would define a new div leave it empty
and you'd put a script tag right after
it we didn't defer execution another
performance no no we didn't have a Dom
framework to handle any cross browser
functionality this we had you know that
framework war happened and we still
hadn't picked one yet some words on
images basically the UI am
that are part of a product would get
uploaded individually to production you
could easily forget how to do that when
you were deploying so they would go
missing for a little while our content
photography is extremely hard for us to
optimize we have a lot of pride in our
photography there's a lot of resistance
and making them smaller or not featuring
them is largely on our on our pages we
did some experiments with lossless
compression we actually for color
novices we noticed some colors changing
and whatever these these tools were
there's a whole department here that has
color correction and the red walls don't
appear in their areas so that they don't
have a little bit of red dilution and on
their screens to do this color
correction it's basically a manual
process to resize these images we have a
lot of them and in order for them to be
fast and having them be smaller people
have to cut them and make sure they
don't crop something out of the picture
because it's manual it doesn't happen a
lot other concerns for the business we
have these editorial constraints like I
mentioned earlier producers have a need
to adjust based on what's happening in
the news so we use this free form module
where they can drop any bit of HTML code
it doesn't even have to be balanced tags
so this can easily mess up our page but
they have the freedom to do that and we
have to be able to handle styles and
scripts occurring in them and ads of
course their topic their top level
objects in our Dom they're not treated
in any special way they bring their own
copies of Dom frameworks in we get older
versions of jQuery we saw an ad that
tried to encapsulate prototype which if
you're familiar with how prototype j/s
works it modifies built in objects in
the browser you can't actually contain
it in a box so it didn't really work
adds animate as soon as they load we get
a lot of painting issues when animations
happen while the page is loading and
basically they're they are higher in the
Dom order as the page is loading than
our own logo on the home page those ads
you'll see two ads and then you'll see
our logo if you look at the source so
just the caveat all of this history it
wasn't really entirely all bad we do use
a CDN we've had Akamai for a number of
years it's been great we did turn gzip
on in 2007
the bandwidth the bandwidth savings were
actually immediate and there were a lot
of really happy people as soon as we did
that but it wasn't on previously and
it's worth mentioning that we did turn
it on so a new wind for our efforts and
what we were trying to do starting in
2009 to make the site faster 2009 was a
year we were focusing on tools and
libraries we basically built a new build
system for front-end files and this was
our first foray into doing automatic
builds we used to manually on tar
uncompressed files in production and and
we were actually pulling changes from
version control as opposed to somebody's
home directory they would arrange the
files the way they wanted them to appear
we would package them up and someone
would manually unpackage it now it's
coming from version control directly
there were semi stateful rollbacks there
was a rollback mechanism but you could
really only rollback the latest one if
you try to roll back any before that you
would end up in an unknown state and
that was really bad but the really
exciting bit of it was that the other
that there were hooks for build scripts
and we could expand on this process
basically dynamically so we did just
that for our CSS it was the first system
to use those new hooks and we wrote a
bunch of proprietary scripts to not only
unravel the add import directives to
make one concatenated file we wrote a
script to also try and remove some of
the whitespace and the comments this is
all downstream from development work
which is also a really good point we
didn't want our developers to feel that
they couldn't comment their work
adequately while we were doing this we
were working on our CSS framework we we
took the concepts from our design and we
turned them into these base files that
can be used across the site we split
code into reusable modules and actually
tried to reuse them in a sane way we aim
to have a single entry point at the top
of the page while we were doing this we
were also trying to lock down rjs
development we introduced a new
top-level namespace called nytd and the
module pattern also called the
immediately invoked function expression
this is a great way to to wrap all your
variables in a closure although thanks
to Colt I'm now afraid of closures we
introduced prototype j/s as a Dom
library this one bullet point doesn't
really reflect
the amount of meetings and discussions
and debates and fights we had over this
decision but prototype.js
went out in the end we also tried to
write our own proprietary asynchronous
JavaScript loader in the days before
required Jas any of these these lab Jas
any of these loaders they didn't exist
we try to write our own didn't really
work it became a synchronous JavaScript
loader so we started with our homepage
and there's a number of reasons why it's
a it's published very frequently so this
problem with legacy markup really
doesn't become an issue it gets the most
traffic so it has the potential to save
people the most amount of time it has an
isolated implementation basically it's
if something went wrong nothing would go
wrong on other parts of the site and
it's viewed very heavily internally if
something were really bad it'd get
noticed before it got out into
production so in November 2009 we put
our CSS optimizations on the home page
it saved 25 HTTP connections to what are
very small CSS files the first paint
occurred a whole second earlier and the
home page really felt faster and we were
very happy by this so in 2010 we wanted
to continue this this these efforts the
CSS framework basically rolled out to
our section and article pages again we
were focusing on the single entry point
but we never we never optimized them
there were some concerns with these
proprietary scripts and it turns out
later when we did an audit that we were
right to be concerned there were
references to missing files there were
at import cycles it would include be
include see include a and if you're ever
curious about what the browser does to
get out of that I still don't know the
answer and there were syntax errors that
there were Styles not getting applied
because they were typed improperly so we
decided to build a new Jas build system
in 2010 we forked the code base we
wanted to create a clean build and only
only code that was modular and
namespaced would be able to be in this
build basically we had these manifests
of files that had an add import like
syntax in a Jas comment so that they
would be a nerd if the build process
failed
we used Yui compressor for minification
we no longer wanted to write our own
scripts this was well supported at the
time so why not we were focusing on to
build files one at the top one at the
bottom if you're familiar with the best
practices they
say that you're supposed to put your je
s at the bottom of the page so why did
we have them at the top if you remember
that editors can put JavaScript on the
page if we wanted them to use our
frameworks it had to be there before
they could actually run their code so we
put stuff at the top to make sure that
that wouldn't break anything this build
process was executed manually so it
didn't see widespread usage it's
basically almost done only on the home
page and now we have two code bases and
still no automatic build process but
when we did launch these J's changes to
the home page it was pretty drastic we
got a 50% speed-up six seconds down from
12 we were very excited by that
so 2011 was a bit of a slow year as you
can as you might remember if you're fans
in the New York Times we introduced
digital subscriptions in 2011 so
resourcing for this kind of work was
really really hard to come by oh hello I
don't know what I just did all right
there were efforts to optimize our
analytics packaging that we have a lot
of analytics packages and they were kind
of doing some really bad stuff they got
aborted mostly because we were afraid to
break this act these actual reports we
wanted to make sure that the business
was able to analyze things correctly so
we didn't continue that so we used a
series of code reviews and style guides
to make sure that we were enforcing good
standards and best practices to keep the
status quo but at the end of 2011 we
made the decision we decided to replace
prototypes with jQuery site-wide and as
you can imagine this is really really
hard
both actually we needed both them to
coexist during the transition we weren't
going to rewrite everything and launch a
new site on a new framework all at once
so we needed both of them to basically
be around while we did this but in 2012
a group of five developers basically set
out to try and Excise prototype j/s from
article pages we were making really
really excellent progress things were
going great
hours and hours of work and then we
found that there were some inline
scripts that made reference made
references to prototype j/s and if you
remember that we have these static pages
with markup that we can't change we
really have no idea of what's calling
prototype j/s and inline scripts and so
therefore we're not ever able to remove
prototype.js fully from our site so now
we have two frameworks they both
download they're both
and this actually causes some really
strange bugs in older ie
where you don't have a get elements by
classname prototype Jas would add one
and jQuery will detect it and use it it
returns prototype objects and jQuery
says I have no idea what these are and
bales so 2012 also marked the end of
life for this proprietary build system
you basically migrated to a system that
mirrored our entire SVN repositories via
hudson we wrote a new script to
concatenate these CSS imports we needed
feature parity with what we had before
so we had to write something new to make
sure that we could handle it for the
home page which already had it it does
have all these features although CSS
lint is added on the list to catch
syntax errors that didn't exist until
2012 I believe it uses Yui compressor to
do minification and also has to be run
manually so again it's really just
limited to the home page so finally I'm
gonna talk a bit about some efforts in
the modern in modern times of what we're
trying to do to really fix this problem
so we were really gifted a very rare
opportunity by the business in March
2013 the New York Times announced that
it was going to introduce a new article
redesign and it's more for us it's more
than just a new user interface a new
user experience it's really a
technological reboot we've changed
everything about our systems in order to
deal with some of these legacy issues
that we've had so the best thing and I
have an exclamation point here because
and it really doesn't represent our
excitement by this we have dynamic pages
now there's an we no longer have to deal
with an unknown number of permutations
we can actually change our asset URLs on
the fly to bypass the cache as soon as
we do a deploy we pushed a lot of the
user customization into into the client
side we're not doing it on the server so
we can actually cache our pages better
on the back end we introduced html5
boilerplate and moderniser to give us a
nice starting point for these new pages
so now we have a modern build system
using grunt it can be run both in our
developer sandbox 'iz and and Hudson to
prepare a build and most of these web
performers best practices are actually
available as grunt tests already which
made it really easy to integrate some of
some of this great advice for our code
and we're using rpm
packaging for deployments they have very
great roll back support and they're
really easy to use so for style
development we switched to using less
less itself handles concatenation
minification is supported by yui
compressor through the grunt task so
this is really easy to get these two
wins variables and mix-ins allow us to
do some really interesting things in CSS
that we had to do with images before
arrows buttons data URIs and spriting so
earlier this year I wrote a grunt test
that automates the creation of sprite
sheets I don't really know what the the
diction is around about around sprites
and sprite sheets and I don't know what
you what do you call the individual
images in a sprite sheet I have no idea
so I'm making up the terminology
basically the task takes in a bunch of
images and exports not only the combined
sprite sheet but also a bunch of mix-ins
unless with the background coordinates
which makes it not only really easy to
make these combined images you don't
have to maintain them manually it's
really easy for developers to use them
in the code the mix-ins are named after
the image itself so you just put the
image name and you basically get the
sprite and the best part about it is if
the coordinates change because we've
added a new image and if it's
alphabetical and you added a C right all
the images shift a little bit right all
you have to do is rebuild the system and
all the coordinates are updated nobody
has to go in and actually figure
something out and change anything and
we're currently combining about a over I
think over a hundred small images into
one that's 99 saved requests to very
small files that we need for our new
design I'm not showing it here you can
check out the marketing page to see what
it looks like just a heads up for
JavaScript we are we switched to
requirejs this handles again
concatenation and minification in the
grunt task and we also get source Maps
which is something we're really excited
to use for our development no longer we
no longer need a global namespace that's
why the slide is titled
that we're deleting our window dot nytd
namespace we get asynchronous loading of
JavaScript and we basically decided to
focus on larger build files so that once
you've established a connection on
mobile you want to make sure you keep
the latency low that the initial
handshake can be really high so we keep
the we keep these
build files around instead of using a
bunch of individual require.js loads
since we moved a lot of the client
customization to the browser we needed
to make sure we could template properly
so we use underscore J s templates
instead of building with the Dom or any
HTML strings and it's way faster to
precompile you're essentially running a
JavaScript function which is optimized
in the browser grunt can automate this
on this compilation there's a built-in
task to do it and we turn them into a
requirejs module that gets included as
part of our build process so we use
backbone to organize everything into
modules they are reusable and they are
shared across applications if we would
like them to be but the real win is that
they give us a bunch of inherited
functionality so we can we can abstract
out touch events in analytics or some
common element references so that we can
not have we won't have to look them up
all the time and we can get this
functionality and everything very easily
we get event a delegation fewer event
listeners so things run a little more
smoothly and the modules communicate
with each other using events you can
publish events or you can subscribe to
another modules events to find out about
changes so this is the big topic what
did we do about ads we took ads out of
the critical path what we do is on Dom
ready we write the add markup into a new
iframe you just take the frames document
and you document dot write it into the
frame and what happens that the ad
itself calls document dot write you
don't lose your whole page you would
just lose content of the iframe which is
blank to begin with so we don't care
what they do once there once they're in
the frame once they load if they decide
to bust out of the frame they can but we
have this notion of trusted ads that
aren't framed and trusted basically
means that they specifically don't do
things that are bad for page speed and
also if if there's actually a problem
it's very easy for us to get in touch
with them and make the change and this
has been really really effective for us
so this is the results page I don't I
thought it would be great to show you a
comparative slide of our waterfalls to
show you how really dramatic this is
we're not quite ready to show you that
information yet it's still being built
so we're not quite ready to do that but
just to give you an overview before
starting to render the page used to
download over 60 requests it's about 10
now maybe even fewer before we're fully
loaded we had to
load 200 assets it's about 70 now a
start render is under one second in
chrome and document complete is under
three seconds in chrome so this is a
huge win for us before previously
document complete would be about nine
seconds on our article pages so to
answer Steve's question about is web
performance too hard no and yes not it's
really not that hard the optimization
practices are really not that difficult
to begin with and the X there's actually
one tooling that exists to make it
really really really easy to do
however there are some unique challenges
that I think not just big websites but
companies tend to have their own
challenges that people can't solve their
problems for them and not to mention any
legacy decisions such as ours where we
have our static pages that was holding
us back
we found that we did this negative
feedback cycle we had this bad this poor
setup and we tried to do this
proprietary fix to make it better and we
found ourselves slightly worse off than
we were before even though we were
getting slightly faster speed so here's
some stuff that we learned share some
advice it's really worth it to fight to
solve these big difficult problems they
they are the 800-pound gorilla in the
room for a reason fight to solve them
once they're out of your way it really
opens the path to making this a lot
simpler we live in a world where you
don't have to rely on proprietary
systems anymore you might need some
because it's your your business so you
may need to make sure that that you have
all of all your requirements taken care
of but a lot of the tooling exists to
make this very simple I always say that
we should you should you should count
your HTTP connections before you count
bytes in every file do the Big Easy wins
first it's really easy to to combine
files together than it is to figure out
what code is old and needs to be removed
from your files and automate everything
as soon as you introduce manual to the
equation it really doesn't get done so
if you can automate everything it's it's
by far going to to pave the road and
make it really easy so that's it I think
I'm running out of time thank you very
much
I don't think I have time for questions
but I will be around a dinner so if you
want to come find me and I can talk
endlessly about this so please find me I
will share all of my knowledge